we turn to a man who knows all about the
nfl because he he well i mean he runs
his site called pro football talk he
created it he runs it he does uh
uh not one but two shows for nbc sports
on peacock he starts the day with pft
live and ends it with pftpm when
that show is in season his name is mike
florio and he's back here on the rich
eisen show how are you mike
rich i'm doing great you were speaking
of october 17
2010 three bang bang hits in about five
minutes of real time dante robinson hit
desean jackson
brandon merryweather hit todd heap and
james harrison hit muhammad massaquad
and that changed everything when it
comes to the league's enforcement
of hits to the helmet and neck area of
defenseless receivers and hello how are
you yes exactly
see i knew you know you would know that
and and and the only thing i would take
issue with is brandon merriweather went
top rope on todd heap
that was insane out of all i remember
marshall falk
went on game day morning the week after
those hits took place
and saying that desean jackson should
have known to sit down
in the coverage if he would knew what
the coverage was if he actually studied
to know what coverages looked like he
would have sat down and dante robinson
wouldn't have blown him up that he
he pinned that one onto sean jackson
which made us all look at marshall and
go what are you talking about
but um the league just doesn't you know
obviously was just going to stop
all of that in its tracks yeah that's
all changed now and it's on
the defensive back to play with the
right technique
if you hit that helmet and neck area
with your helmet or any other part of
your body a forcible blow to the head or
neck area
of a defenseless player it's an
automatic 15 yards
and involuntary contribution to the
human fund and
potential suspensions over time
mike florio pro football talk always
great for seinfeld reference right here
on the rich eisen show
uh julio jones trade what's what's the
headline to come out of it
do you arthur blank blank try saying
that ten times faster that's what it
came down to arthur blank one of the
first round pick for julio jones
for two reasons one they got a second
round pick for muhammad sunu
during the 2019 season and then they
gave up a second round pick to get
hayden hurst from the ravens
now it was a two plus
uh what was it two plus they got a two
plus a five
for haydenhurst plus a four so the the
the
the fingerprints were there for what
ultimately happened with the two and a
four from the titans
for julio jones in a six it had to be
more than a two
blank wanted a one blank had held out
for a one
and i think when arthur blank realized
where this is going from here
training camp looming mandatory mini
camp in theory julio could have shown up
what do you do with julio jones where
he's got a 15.3 million dollar
injury guarantee and otherwise full
guarantee on his salary if he shows up
for mandatory mini camp what do you do
with him
i think that blind just decided now is
the time to
to get what i can and move on even
though if they had come up with a way to
hold on to julio jones
maybe they would have gotten lucky and
gotten that first rounder later in the
year i just think that
that they were ready to move on and you
know there's a chance the titans are
going to move on if titans move on what
do you have so
it was time it was smart and they got
the best deal they could under
a bad set of circumstances where it was
well known within the organization the
player wanted out
and so what comes with julio is the
contract right
and and what what are those numbers and
how do you see julio handling his new
digs
in tennessee on that front alone x and
o's aside yeah rich full contract
with none of it paid by the falcons when
the titans traded for ryan tan hill a
couple years ago the dolphins paid five
million dollars of tan hills
compensation very different circumstance
at the
at that time and at this time but the
the titans are gonna pay the full
fifteen point three million
guaranteed for skill injury and cap
there's a two million guarantee next
year they pick up the whole contract but
here's the thing
even though the jones contract which was
renegotiated three years ago
had a new money average of 22 million
plus per year
right now it's three years 38 million in
change works out to about 12.7 million
per year
watch for julio jones to either want a
new deal
on the way in the door or go out this
year
have a great season and then turn around
after 2021 and say all right
it's time to take care of me financially
but that that's what whoever was trading
for
julio jones was going to end up buying
and i think that's one of the reasons
why
the falcons couldn't get that that first
round pick you're taking on fifteen
point three million
in salary obligation in a year when the
cap is down a net of twenty five million
and you have a guy who's gonna want
another major contract
as soon as now and at the latest after
this season
well and then putting it all together
though mike mike florio pro football
talk here on the rich eisen show
um put it all together though uh i'm
saying that no matter how upset a falcon
fan might be
that that julio was gone um what what
about the fan bases of teams
that could have gotten julio and didn't
cough up the two
and the four or try and beat it with a
two and a three and it's not even in the
same draft
it's two years ago i think that it's
incumbent on
those teams to get word to the media
that covers those teams
to explain that it was more
than just giving up those draft picks it
was the salary obligation the
expectation that
he's going to want a new contract and
then the nagging question
about his health last dream is nine
games
with a hamstring injury the tights are
comfortable that he's fine and
look rich one of the realities of
life in the nfl and julio jones isn't
the first he's not the last and i don't
mean this in a pejorative way at all but
there will be occasions when a guy who
otherwise could play
doesn't play because of an injury that
if he was motivated if he was happy
if the team was a contender he'd find a
way to play through
and i think when the titans did their
due diligence they came to the
conclusion that the relationship was
fractured
the team wasn't good and julio
jones was airing on the side of
protecting his hamstring and protecting
his future
because the alternative is go out there
and and risk further injury
for a team that's going nowhere and uh
and and but but still that's part of the
risk you take on if you're the rams
or one of these other teams jaylen
ramsey was confused why the rams didn't
go all in to get julio jones and i'm
sure plenty of other fan bases
have players on the team fans
others who are like what's going on
what's going on is it's so much more
than just
those draft picks and those other
dynamics are things you have to feel
comfortable with
you're not going to make that trade well
i mean and in terms of the dynamics for
any any team in the nfc any fan of a
team in the nfc you could just forget it
i mean like the falcons
unless you were going to cough up the
one now we're having a different
conversation
but um you know the falcons were not
trading him in conference
and so what about teams outside of this
conference i mean what about a team you
know um
like the cults who have the cap space
and now he's in this division i mean
this is a hell
of a downhill
physical troika that's at the disposal
of ryan tannehill who is also
one of the best run throw threats
in the nfl from that position too not a
lot of people put tannehill in the
same category as kyler murray or
uh lamar jackson but you really can when
you look at the statistics about how
much of an issue he was in the red zone
personally
himself not just throwing it now you've
got these three guys too
it's it's kind of crazy like maybe you
make that trade just to prevent it from
happening
well you know when you think about it
there haven't been many of these
quartets where you have the quarterback
the running back and two great receivers
the colts
in the days of payton and marvin
harrison and reggie wayne
and edgar and james and you know even
though james was gone by the time they
finally won a super bowl
the the rams with marshall and kurt and
isaac bruce and tory holt you know it's
one thing to have three when you have
that second receiver
whose skill set is virtually identical
to the other receiver that that's
trouble and you make a great point
if i'm the falcons i'm doing everything
i can
to get the colts come to the table and
one of the best arguments is titans are
going to get him if you don't
now chris balor the gem of the colts
isn't going to fall for that kind of
stuff and i think he keeps a very steady
hand
yeah and he's not going to get caught up
in something that he knows
doesn't fit with what he's trying to do
and and i really do think i don't know
this
but i wouldn't be surprised if chris
ballard was
leery of where this goes if julio jones
comes in this year
has a big season then what do you do and
and don't they are
i think they're what they've got a
second that can become a one that's been
committed to the eagles so they didn't
even really have a second round pick and
play for next year
because that too can become a one until
we know what the condition is both
picks are tied up so that that may have
been an impediment as well
but you know the colts at one point were
fairly high up on the betting odds and
then they just plummeted so somebody
somewhere
caught wind of the idea that the colts
weren't going to get in on it and the
titans
had to the people in the league the
titans were always
the favorite and as of a week week and a
half ago the prevailing thought was
titans for a two and that's what it was
plus a little bit extra
to to get the falcons to feel better
about the trade mike florio here on the
rich eisen show from pro football talk
at pro football talk i must follow on
twitter and so much more
what's the scoop on rogers we're uh
eight days away from
the mandatory mini camp and all eyes
peeled there
what do you think were eyes peeled for
how about the
the mark murphy column from saturday
and and it really is stunning he wasn't
even asked a question
about aaron rodgers and he answers a
question that
isn't even about aaron rodgers by saying
the aaron rodgers situation has divided
our fan base and all by the way we have
chosen to not
address the situation publicly yeah
except coming out and saying that
the situation's divided the fan base i i
think that the packers
realize that roger's biggest fear is
having the fans turn on him
and i look
that that those things weren't written
accidentally or extemporaneously this
was planned this was read this was
revised this is a deliberate message
from the packers to rogers and everyone
else
and i think what they're trying to do is
get rogers to realize the fans are
already turning and they're daring him
to not show up
because i think what the fans have done
rich ever since the
stuff that bubbled up around the draft
and it lasted for a few days
the fans had some consternation at least
those who
like to yell at me via email and twitter
but then they kind of settled down
and i think their attitude is we won't
believe it till we see it
so the moment he doesn't show up whether
to the mandatory mini camp
or training camp the moment he doesn't
show up
that's when it goes to defcon one for
packers fans and and i think that mark
murphy's trying to make sure rogers
realizes that i think deep down
frankly if i'm mark murphy to and i
don't know that i disagree with this
mindset i think deep down he wants him
to not show up
we'll get 30 million plus we'll trade
him next march anyway
and we get a year to figure out what we
have in jordan love
i don't know i mean well i i find that
interesting that you say
again you're referring to a monthly
column that murphy writes for
packers.com
the situation we face with aaron rodgers
has divided our fan base he wrote
the emails and letters that i've
received reflect this fact
and he said as i wrote here last month
we remain committed to resolving things
with aaron and want him to be our
quarterback in 2021 and beyond
that's an interesting addendum we are
working to resolve the situation and
realize that the less
both sides say publicly the better but
except that the fan base has decided
this is beautiful about it i mean they
they are they are twisting the knife and
aaron rodgers with this they really
are well i mean it's because he's
twisted back well i mean
his his whole conversation i don't know
if you were on after it or
we haven't talked about it his whole
conversation with kenny mayne was
essentially to just turn the
heat up on gouda kuns to kick the can
down the road not be committal not say
not give anything that makes it seem
like he's not coming back not make
anything
seem like he is um talking about the
people
and the organization not not uh putting
stock in the people and now here's
mark murphy talking about the people who
email who are the packer fans who email
them saying stick to your guns
email address you know what i mean like
who said this again i
my own experiences it's not the case
they're not red state blue state yet
they could be
they could be if he doesn't show up but
i i think that they decided collectively
at least based upon the things i've
noticed and i
i get interactions in many different
formats i've just noticed a sense that
it's wait and see
because why get bent out of shape when
he has yet
to fail to show up for anything
mandatory enrich what we haven't talked
since
aaron was on with kenny mayne and that
the thing that that really resonated
with me
when aaron said that that he threw a
wrench in there
their plan is paraphrasing when he won
the mvp last year he believes
he believes right or wrong that they
were going to flip from him to jordan
love after the 2020 season
and that but for him when in the mvp
that's what the plan was they were going
to implement that's what he believed
i i would agree with him if he believes
that because you know and that's the one
thing that
we've been talking about on this show as
well and i do believe with you before as
well is that
you know in the same way that terry
bradshaw said that uh you know that
rogers shouldn't pay attention to
somebody drafted in the first round
similar to the fact he didn't
get phased by mark malone being drafted
in the 1980 first round draft
it's totally apples and oranges because
there was no physical
i mean there was no uh monetary
construct attached
to mark malone's first contract in the
nfl like the one that is with jordan
love
that that requires getting the player on
the field to see if a second contract is
worth it and certainly if a fifth year
option is worth it you need to see time
and we're seeing daniel jones
year three for him they still don't have
an answer we saw sam donald shipped off
to carolina you still don't have an a
now it's carolina trying to find an
answer on
on sam darnold one year went by with
jordan love not even
dressing so damn straight rogers threw a
wrench in it
with an mvp campaign don't you think oh
absolutely
now i don't know that they would have
had the nerve
to just go ahead and go ahead and do it
but
yeah i know sims is i think the
the president of the aaron rodgers fan
club and i know
last year based on 2019 yeah he he was
he was pointing out that that rogers
seemed to be slipping a little bit but
was still great
you know they're trying to do the bill
belichick thing they're trying to get
ahead of the curve make a decision a
year early instead of a year later i
just think they outsmarted themselves
with this one
and they've really painted themselves
into a corner and i don't know how they
get out of it
and i i i really do think that deep down
if mark murphy were attached to a lie
detector i think his preference would be
rogers doesn't show up the fan base
turns on him
we get 35 million back that we can
reinvest we find out what jordan love
has we don't worry about aaron rodgers
going somewhere else this year and
winning the super bowl and we trade him
in march i really do believe rich if
they trade him now they're getting less
than what they would get if they trade
him in march because you're gonna have
ten teams at the table in march now you
got the broncos and maybe the raiders
and you're getting twenty twenty two
draft picks anyway whether it's now
or march i would just wait till then and
try to make it like peyton manning 2.0
where they're lining up out the door for
a crack at aaron rodgers
so uh let's just game this out before i
let you go mike you know rogers is smart
enough to know when he's being managed
or gamed or
outfoxed what would his move with david
dunby
if that's what the move that the packers
are planning to say what would his move
be
if if he if he moves his queen's gambit
piece to this
part of the chessboard and the packers
respond as you just did
what's what's roger's response just to
sit at home
and and and hope that jeopardy calls him
in the meantime i mean like seriously i
i
what would be his maneuver to to get out
of that and get to a spot and win
this year for another team i'm
envisioning rogers in hawaii after
consuming one or more legal substances
or otherwise and looking up and seeing
the chess pieces upside down moving
around in front of him but correct
i i i think
that at the end of the day he's showing
up
and i think it's going to be one of the
most awkward
compelling story lines
we've ever witnessed because it's going
to be every week
every press conference every practice
we said on pft live that if brian good
acoustic is going to go in the vicinity
of the practice field where two cups
and a helmet maybe two and
a bit because he he that he betrayed his
feelings
two weeks ago with kenny main on this i
love my teammates i love my coaches i
love the fans okay fine then you're
going to be there
then you're going to be there you got a
problem with the boss who doesn't have a
problem with the boss at some level we
all got a problem with the boss at some
level
not us though rich that's right but
but so what so what you you you you deal
with it you move forward just like
russell wilson is in seattle
mike appreciate the call let's let's
chat again next week let's
let's keep our eyes peeled on this
thanks again for that thanks for your
time always
that's uh mike florio pro football talk
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here